so I've been watching Game of Thrones a
lot of people have asked me what I think
about this show over the past few years
a lot of people and I never had anything
to say because I wasn't watching the
show my wife loved it some of my best
friends loved it and they would
constantly try to get me to watch the
show and I was like I'll eventually do
it so I took the beginning of 2019 and I
binge the show and I watched the entire
show in a few weeks actually leading up
to season 8 and I was able to experience
all of that in a very quick time so that
I could talk about the series finale and
my overall thoughts on the show which
I'm about to do in just a second but
before I get farther in the review I do
want to give a thank you to the sponsor
for this episode and that is raid shadow
legends a brand new RPG for smartphones
released in 2019 it's extremely
immersive and one of the most ambitious
games you're going to find on the
smartphone it can be compared with some
of the biggest PC and console titles and
since we're going to be talking about a
dragon very soon here in just a second
check out this dragon the game features
[Music]
it has all the features you'd expect
from a brand-new RPG title amazing
storyline awesome 3d graphics giant boss
fights PvP battles and hundreds of
champions to collect and customize I
downloaded the game I played it I had a
good time it reminded me of some of the
old-fashioned RPGs I've always liked and
surprisingly the game is completely free
which is awesome considering the level
of detail the game has raids special
launch tournament is happening right now
and it's getting big real fast so go to
the description of this video download
raid only through my link to get 50,000
silver immediately and here's the
coolest part you'll be entered into a
special launch tournament to compete
with other players for in-game prizes or
physical prize packs so please do check
out the links for iOS and Android in the
description below
thank you so much to raid Shadow Legends
for sponsoring this video let's talk
about that Game of Thrones series finale
because I have a lot to say so my wife
my friends and many of you have been
imploring me to watch this show for the
past like seven to eight years people
have been begging me to see this show
and I've always put it off because I
have this thing with TV shows I'm afraid
to get invested in a show love it so
much and then either it gets cancelled
or it ends poorly and I feel like I've
wasted my time
so with Breaking Bad i binge the entire
show when it was in its final season and
I loved it I loved the finale I loved
how it wrapped up in my opinion Breaking
Bad is a perfect show it rarely had a
misstep it possibly didn't have a
misstep Breaking Bad was incredible and
and that show was very rare there are so
many shows where I have gotten invested
in them and they've either ended in a
horrible way or they got cancelled and I
got burned a lot with with shows and so
I kind of became of this mentality where
unless I have it streaming or easy
access to it or like really interested
in seeing the show which does happen I
tend to not watch TV shows until they've
had a fairly successful run and I'm like
okay okay so they had a long time to
prove how good they were so that I could
watch that show and then get really
invested in and that's what I did with
Game of Thrones because I heard nothing
but good things about Game of Thrones
for
at least season 1 through 7 I would say
like I've heard plenty of things about
season 7 and 6 and 5 and people not
liking everything that happens but for
the most part people seem to be pleased
with seasons 1 through 7 you know for
the most part consensus wise and so I
was like you know what alright season 8
is starting it's the final one I'm gonna
watch the whole show and I binge
seven seasons in about two and a half
weeks so that was an emotional journey
that took me in many places and I felt
very depressed on some days and very
happy on some days and then very excited
and but it was a different thing for me
because so many people have spent years
with this show and I was able to
experience it condensed I was able to
feel the arcs that they were setting up
in a very quick period of time I didn't
have to remember like what happened like
six years ago
no that was a couple days ago so
watching and discussing season 8 with my
wife and my friends has been a
magnificent experience for me because I
have been completely on the outside of
the Game of Thrones event for all of
these years and so most people have
these grand built up expectations about
what they wanted to see I didn't because
I watched the whole show in a few weeks
and I really enjoyed it
it's a masterful show I mean incredibly
well directed and written and acted and
she's the the fucking visuals and the
cinematography god I mean like there's
there's very few shows that have ever
gotten close to that level of
craftsmanship on TV my favorite episode
still to this day is battled the
bastards I love that episode it's my
favorite battle I love the finale I
guess let's just give the spoiler
warning upfront here we're gonna talk
full spoilers about all of Game of
Thrones including the last episode so if
you haven't seen any of that
that's your warning love the ending of
battle of the bastards Ramsay getting
mold by those dogs and Sansa just
walking off but setting battle episodes
aside my favorite dramatic moment was
the entire finale of the laws of gods
and men Tyrion finally standing up to
his father when he was on trial
admitting to the things he feels
confessing to the things that he's
afraid of and standing up for himself
was just I got goose bumps
when I watched that episode and I
thought that Peter Dinklage throughout
this entire show was just masterful he's
my favorite character Tyrion is for sure
at least seasons one through like six
ish he makes some really strange choices
for the last few seasons and they kind
of did away with the whole Tyrion is
clever and smart an amazing thing which
sucks but nevertheless he remained my
favorite character and surprisingly I
was able to for the most part avoid
spoilers for Game of Thrones somehow I
knew that Ned Stark died it's pretty
hard to avoid that and I knew that a lot
of people died at the red wedding but I
didn't know who and so I had
expectations for that but I didn't know
like what would happen but for the most
part I didn't really know anything else
so I was able to have a very fresh
experience with the show and I enjoyed
almost all of it season 8 though has
been a mixed bag for me which we're
gonna start talking about now there's a
lot of things that have happened in this
season that fans hate and choices that
were made that fans hate and there's of
course been petitions and boycotts and
all kinds of crazy nonsense on the
internet as usual whenever fans don't
like the way something they love is
going and I was fine with the first
three episodes of season 8 the long
night looked awful on streaming it's
gonna look amazing on blu-ray and I'm
excited to see that episode on blu-ray
but my biggest issue with season 8 even
though I liked the first three episodes
before I saw the fourth episode was that
it just felt rushed it felt like so much
was happening so quickly and while I
could understand certain choices that
were being made it just felt so crammed
and that could have something to do with
the fact that most of the seasons except
for 7 had 10 episodes so a lot was
happening really fast and arcs were just
flying all over the place the night king
was like an afterthought really and from
the perspective of someone who watched
the whole show in two and a half weeks
though he's kind of an afterthought
throughout the entire show they never
really knew what to do with him I
remember I forget it was season 3 or
season 4 I don't remember one of the
seasons ended with the White Walkers
just marching and you were
like oh shit what's happening and then I
of course click next episode and I
watched like an entire half of the next
season before a white Walker or the
night king even showed up like the final
season before that teases them and then
they barely show up and then hardhome
happened which was incredible but for
the most part the show just didn't
really know what to do with the night
king or the White Walkers they were just
sort of like these background
antagonists of an undead army that will
create some cool battle scenes and so I
wasn't surprised that his death was also
an afterthought and it kind of came and
went one of my biggest issues with
season 8 before we get to the finale
because I got things to say I've never
talked about Game of Thrones even once
on this channel so I apologize if you're
a new viewer and you're waiting for me
to talk about the finale but I have
never discussed Game of Thrones on this
channel and I have a few things to say
one of my biggest concerns with the show
is what they did with Arya and I believe
it was season 6
by the way Arya is competition with
Tyrion for my favorite character I love
her she might be my favorite character
but Tyrion is just so fucking awesome
but they they take her and do this
training with her in season 6 she learns
how to be someone of mini faces and she
can you know imitate people and and and
she steals their faces and she's
basically Ethan Hunt so that's fucking
cool what are they gonna do with that
well she does some stuff she kills
everybody responsible for the red
wedding that's great revenge and then
throughout all of season 8 she never
uses disability like at the end of the
long night the night King is approaching
bran in the wheelchair and I was
positive that Arya was just gonna gut
him right there and take off brans face
and it would have been Arya in this this
moment revealing that she would have had
to I guess killed bran and taken his
face and that bran would have made that
sacrifice because that's what the
three-eyed Raven thought he was supposed
to do or that's why he was kept alive
throughout this whole show and I don't
know it just would have been a really
fucked up in an unexpected way instead
of her like jumping out of the shadows
and it would have given brand more of a
reason to be in the show all this time
because now I'll say this my least
favorite character in the entire show is
bran
I do not like
this character what they did with him he
spent the entire season underground
grasping a tree limb and becoming the
three-eyed Raven and I just don't like
that character I find him very boring
whenever they cut back to him even
before that I was like okay it's
whatever there's been two moments with
brand that I thought brought out
something and that was um whole doors
big moment and then when Jamie sees him
in season 8 and you get this look on
Jamie like oh shit there's the kid that
I I did this - but then he don't really
even get that because bran is like I'm
not bran I'm the three-eyed Raven and so
it just feels so forced and strange and
I would have loved that that could have
been another way that Arya could have
used her abilities because she doesn't
use these abilities at all throughout
this season this incredible gift she has
and she never fucking uses it it makes
it feel like all of her training was
just this waste I'm not gonna get too
much into the prophecies that were
foretold throughout this show some of
them came true others seem to have just
been forgotten about I'm not gonna
concern myself with that because as soon
as they were making prophecies in the
first few seasons I was like oh this is
not a good idea
you're just not gonna want to do all of
this stuff I know you're not and of
course some of them didn't really work
out and there's stuff that's that's in
the novels that was never in the show as
well prophecy wise because I actually
have started to read the book and it's
good george RR martin is a genius that
being said there's just a lot that they
did in those first three episodes that
felt very rushed then we get to the last
of the Starks and things start to get to
a strange point for me didn't hate it
yet you know and I and I didn't loathe
what I was seeing but I could see that
it was going in a direction that didn't
feel earned yet it didn't feel warranted
yet so when we get to the bells episode
and Danny is up on that dragon and she
hears the bells and the city has
surrendered and everyone has laid down
their swords and she has one
I mean her dreams have come true and she
decides fuck all of you I'm going to
kill all of you in a horrible fire men
women children innocence everybody's
just going to fucking die so
I can sit on the throne even though I
just won the throne I'm going to take
the throne and the excuse seemed to be
well her father was the Mad King and now
she's the mad Queen and so I'm like
alright look I don't like the way this
is going
it feels rushed it's not that I hate
that she would make that choice okay for
people who like that choice I'm fine
with the choice it's getting to it it's
the execution of getting there it's the
amount of time we have with these
characters to understand what would lead
her to make that choice because again
watch the whole show in two weeks I
remember all the people she burned the
people she punished the people she
nailed to signs okay I remember all of
the fucked-up shit she did but those
were all events that had a cause and
effect the cause was some horrible
violence or threat of her being
assaulted or killed and the effect was
her saying nope that's not gonna happen
because now I'm gonna make things right
in the case of King's Landing there was
no cause she was just pure effect she
just murdered and slaughtered a million
people who didn't do anything to her
I get being pissed at Cersei I get being
pissed at the Lannister army okay but
the men women and children who were
melted there's no cause there and so the
getting to that moment it just did not
feel earned for me and maybe two or
three more episodes could have done that
so let's talk about the series finale I
got some of my buddies together my wife
we sat down we watched it tonight and we
were excited to see where it would go
but we were a little cautious you know
because like the season was a little
mixed so far and before the episode
started though we had a discussion we
went out to eat and we we talked about
who our least favorite character in the
entire series was and unanimously
everybody said bran so you could
probably imagine what we went through
about halfway through the series finale
when Tyrion looks at bran and says you
have this great story and you should be
the king the entire
room erupted okay I wish I was reporting
it
everyone erupted and it was actually
kind of hilarious unfortunately because
I felt bad because my friends have been
watching this show for like eight years
I watched it for two weeks so I didn't
have this this pent up built up insane
expectations or desires but I knew I
didn't want it to be brand I was like
that's just stupid and I didn't like
what they were doing with Danny either
because she just seemed like this crazy
person who just went nuts and it just it
didn't really work for me I liked what
they were doing with Jon Snow and I
thought potentially he could be a good
person a good candidate for the Iron
Throne or maybe Sansa or even Arya but I
just in but bran was just the one where
I was like that's not what I expected
and that's something I want to talk
about yeah I understand why bran could
be a good choice for the throne because
he's like this omnipresent person now
and he can see things other people can't
and he'll probably make really wise
decisions in everything it's just that
aspects of the writing now and the
lead-up to this just feel so messy there
was an episode in season 7 where brand
said something about how he could never
be Lord of anything I get that he's not
a lord now he's a king but a king is
above the Lord so if he doesn't want to
be a lord of anything then then how is
he suddenly a king well you could say to
me he doesn't actually want to be king
he's just the best person for the job
that's not true because he says to
Tyrion why do you think I came all this
way
meaning that he probably planned this
all along it's entirely possible that he
told John of his true heritage knowing
that Jon would then tell Danny that
Danny would get pissed kill everybody in
King's Landing and then John would kill
Danny
and then bran could be king so he just
kind of like sat around and waited for
things to happen I mean that's kind of
what he did throughout the entire show
actually hmm yeah I talked to my buddies
about this I actually think that brand
should have died in the pilot when Jaime
pushed him out of the
no I think that should have been it for
him I do not like the whole three-eyed
Raven thing in fact I kind of really
hate it it's my least favorite aspect of
the entire show and I found the
character just as a person is boring
just a very boring character that kept
cutting back - and cutting back - and I
just I don't really feel like he brought
much to this show but he's like the arc
of the whole show he's the first big
dramatic thing that happens in the end
of the pilot and now he's the king and
the the series finale so my least
favorite character is apparently the
most important aspect of the whole show
that's great still I'm level-headed
about this show I've had very little
investment in it just a few weeks and so
I've had no built up thoughts or you
know extreme once and I can't really be
that mad you know I'm just sort of like
wow that was a really disappointing
season for such a great show and I can't
imagine how people feel a bit who've
been investing so much time into this
show over the past few years but this
right here is really the main reason
that I don't watch that much TV because
you can hear that a show is perfection
for year after year after year and if
they don't stick the landing it kind of
makes things hard and it makes rewatch
ability really bad - I'm gonna say this
though this is not a horrible season
there's plenty of moments in this season
that I liked I loved Brienne getting
knighted thought that was amazing I
actually cried but then of course Jamie
turns his back on her and like well I
hit it and I quit it by bitch and he
just leaves I was like what the fuck
okay go back to Cersei that's cool I
liked Tyrion with his tearful goodbye
with his brother in this episode and
when he was still alive the
cinematography the visuals the acting my
god the score this is like technical
brilliance some of the best of that side
of the production I've ever seen on TV
it's really just the writing the
characters just shifted a lot and said
and did things that didn't make sense to
me and made choices that that I just I
didn't understand
what they were thinking and I think a
lot of this comes down to one of the
biggest issues when you attempt taboos
the unexpected and the unpredictable in
the extreme which that's Game of Thrones
this show is filled with taboos there's
so many of them and the show is very
shocking throughout the entire run time
there's constant extremes that the
writers are are forcing these characters
to endure which makes for great
television but then you have to wrap it
up somehow and this entire season is
filled with more of those extremes and
more of those unexpected unpredictable
moments yes all of that is true but it
just doesn't work anymore because it
doesn't fit in with the rest all of the
extremes for the most part save for a
few elements of certain seasons worked
there were just a few choices I was like
okay that's too far I don't need that we
don't need that there were just a few
moments like that that where I was like
I got the point already you don't also
have to do this to this character
totally understand that but in the case
of this season it felt like they were
just like hey let's just do all this
crazy shit and people will think it's
amazing and nobody will be able to guess
this maybe that's true but that doesn't
mean it works as a story it doesn't mean
that the characters have reached a
logical conclusion and again I must
stress for those who like the way this
season has gone that's cool totally but
it's not for me a case of don't like
what the characters did it's a case of
too much happen too quick not enough
time to sell these choices I'm fine with
John killing Danny I'm sort of okay with
her making the choice to kill all those
people if they can find a thematic
reason for it to work what I preferred
her to just swarm King's Landing and
burn down the red keep yeah but again if
you like the way season 8 went I can get
behind most choices it's just that I
think it should have had maybe eight
episodes a couple more to just really
flesh out what's going on because
there's so many things that just don't
make sense like the smartest character
in the whole show is Tyrion but he
brings everybody into the crypt during
the long night when
undead are coming so he brings everybody
to be safe in the place filled with dead
people like it just there's so many
choices that just don't work for me like
that and it bugs me to have to to say
that because a lot of the show I loved
and this is very much so for me a case
of just not sticking the landing but I
have to give it to these writers and the
directors and everybody on this crew and
the actors for creating a groundbreaking
show genuinely that for all of these
years has been amazing
they created a great show and they did
really great things with it but the way
they decided to end this really didn't
work for me
another thing about the serious finale
that bugged me is it was just so drawn
out there were so many scenes that just
went and went like they were trying to
push the runtime Tyrion slowly walking
through the rubble Jon slowly walking up
the stairs we got that great shot of the
dragon wings behind Danny
but then there's more drawn-out
sequences of people talking in rooms and
then we get a sequence for Tyrion
straightens the chairs and I'm just
thinking to myself this is the finale of
this epic show that people have been
yelling at me to watch for the past
eight years I didn't expect it to be
like this that's the highest level of
disappointment that I can have because I
watch the whole show in a few weeks and
yeah I don't like the way season 8 went
for the most part it's a very mixed bag
for me as is this finale but I can't be
as disappointed or as angry as some fans
are and also I'm just not that kind of
guy
I I'm always on the side of creators
because they're trying to create
something they're trying to put
something out there they're working on
it and they're hoping that people like
it but sometimes choices are made that
are so short-sighted and so
incomprehensible that I just can't
support that and a lot of season 8 left
me feeling that way but still overall as
a show it's a great show and there's a
lot to love in the show but the finale
just it just it wasn't there for me so
yeah I finally watched Game of Thrones I
will try to do some more TV show reviews
in the future it's just that I kind of
like to wait until I can
feel the show out see how it's gone like
our people satisfied with you know the
majority of it and I'm like okay I can
invest that much time into this thing
and then I feel excited about talking
about it if you guys did see the Game of
Thrones series finale which I hope he
did because I just spoiled the whole
goddamn thing what did you guys think of
it I'm curious to know because I do feel
like this is gonna be very polarizing
the whole season has been polarizing and
so I really want to know what people
think of this episode guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more views very soon if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]